a bunch of questions uh but i have to
start millie with the first question for
you
um what do we need to do to get an ola
home sequel
uh email netflix
is there any plans for that i hope so
if you know stephen it's like text me
let me know because then i can open my
schedule
i completely understand um so this is
this is kind of a jokey question but go
with me um every time we write anything
about godzilla
versus kong uh every comment is why
don't they just kiss
so my big question is did did director
adam wingert ever tell you guys
why godzilla and kong don't kiss
yeah are they like different heights
that'd be super awkward like would like
king kong have to stand on like a little
apple box
maybe and it's like i feel like godzilla
would be very touchy with his forehands
i feel like godzilla would feel like
don't i wouldn't be making things like
that
julian i feel like no i feel like kong's
a little bit like
yeah i think it's like i i think there
was like wait a
kind second just kind of in the space
by the way i appreciate you guys doing
that um have either of you or both of
you seen atlanta
yes yes
i'm going to rewatch it soon because i
kind of i remember when i first met
brian i kind of skipped through it and i
just love him as paperboy he's amazing
well i wanted to ask you what it was
like working with paperboy
um it was so cool i remember that so
it's like you know when you work with an
actor and you've seen them in something
before and you really enjoyed it well
i don't know if you know this stephen
but i'm assuming you do you're an
amazing guy
anyway um i work with an actor and i was
like i don't want to say it because you
know i look like a fan
but i remember like a week and i was
like bro like i've i'm gonna sit down
and watch atlanta
but i just want to say i've watched a
few first episodes and you are amazing
as paper boy
and i love um i love donald glover um i
just broke
just yeah it's a really cool trick yeah
um
by the way steven he says this but he
didn't
watch stranger things until after
the film so he's like i love brianna's
paperboy
hey what about me
stranger things was like so cool it was
so cool
the way you say it immediately makes me
think you're lying
because i don't know is it demi gorgon
the big thing in the sky or is that the
lizard steven hey steven did you like
stranger things
uh i may or may not have watched strange
i'm joking with you of course the
stranger things are fantastic
please i was about to be a kangaroo
literally just be like
pissed up i've been friendly with sean
for a long time
and was supporting the show before it
came out and was like
yeah oh that's so awesome oh that's cool
yeah we were called montauk so if you
knew us when we were called monto you're
a real one
i don't know about that but i want to
ask you guys i got to switch back to the
movie real quick
if you guys weren't in this movie or
even if just watching it as a fan
would you normally be rooting for
godzilla or would you normally be
rooting for kong
and why i would be rooting for the
godzilla because the monkey is cool
he's swinging on his trees he's doing
everything
people already know this on the trailer
here's a giant axe so he's a tool man
call him bob the builder
this man is going crazy that's why
i like king kong but godzilla and his
small arms will do as well
godzilla for the win he's misunderstood
and people just need to understand the
fact that he can't communicate like kong
ken you know
it's not his fault nobody taught him
how's he supposed to know he's a loner
i'm not at sea under the sea
everything's okay godzilla isn't a
midlife crisis
no he's not absolute you're in a midlife
crisis
don't talk about my man's life i'm not
even midlife
i'm not even half-life well you're going
through a teenage crisis okay we'll see
it
nobody's telling you thank you on that
note uh listen thank you guys so much
hi stephen good luck with the speed
dating
thank you on to the next